[Música]
hola mi nombre es ángel revuelta
fundador dorking estudio una startup
dedicada a la impresión 3d y vengo a
platicarles un poco de innovación y
monetización los orcos fueron por fin
capaces de aterrizar en el planeta
capital pero sus goblins exploradores
les avisaron de una gran partida de
guerra de demonios que se acercaba a su
posición inteligentemente el jefe de
ellos ordenó poner a sus cañones
estratégicamente apuntando hacia la gran
receta central que se forma mente las
ruinas de la ciudad pero eso no fue
suficiente oleadas de moscas el caos
atacaron sus cañones seguidas por un
príncipe demonio del caos y oleadas
interminables de demonios obligaron a
este grandioso guerrero orco a retirar
sus tropas
esto pasó el fin de semana pasado en mi
noche de juegos de mesa con mis amigos
cuando salí de la universidad mi sueño
era crear un start-up de videojuegos
durante mucho tiempo estuve buscando
gente que compartía estos mismos ideales
conmigo cuando los encontré formamos un
pequeño estudio empezamos a participar
en japonés en eventos en premios y
empezamos a ganar todo esto iba tan bien
que tiene el 2016 nos invitaron a
participar en el tokyo game show en
japon presentando nuestro videojuego
educativo biblia nuestra gran idea
crear un videojuego grande que fuera
capaz de monetizar mucho dinero una vez
que estuviera terminado pero esa misma
idea fue minando nuestros sueños ya que
no teníamos sustentos necesarios para
nuestro día a día todos tuvimos que
buscar trabajo y abandonar este proyecto
el que era mi socio recibió una oferta
laboral acá en cancún para fundar un
estudio de videojuegos el mejor estudio
videojuego del país a los seis meses me
contratan a mí entre mi socio y a mí se
nos encarga la tarea de crear el mejor
equipo de trabajo que hay en méxico para
crear videojuegos lo creamos la idea de
la empresa era sencilla crear un
videojuego tan grande y tan monetizables
que llegáramos al éxito y a la cima pero
después de dos años el dinero se terminó
y la empresa tuvo que cerrar estas dos
experiencias me llevaron a preguntarme
si existen formas diferentes de
monetización y cómo estas formas
diferentes comunicación pueden ayudar a
las startups a sobrevivir hoy en día
todos nos hablan de innovar investigar
emprender pensar fuera de la caja pero
pocos nos hablan de que es la
monetización y sobre todo la importancia
de tener una economía saludable dentro
de tu startup para empezar vamos a
platicar
qué es monetización la monetización es
un término sumamente sencillo es el
proceso de convertir algo lo que sea en
dinero sabiendo ese término que es una
economía saludable según varias fuentes
una economía saludable mente un start o
puede definirse como una empresa que
depende en mayor medida de sus ventas
que de inversión externa llámese
créditos empresariales bonos o ayuda
gubernamental cuando esto realmente
tenemos que preguntarnos cuál es la
mejor manera de monetizar con nuestra
estar todos de una manera disfrutaba
siempre pensando en el usuario según el
financiero el 75 por ciento de las
startups en méjico fracasan en palabras
de leticia gasca directora de foco máis
la principal causa es la falta de
recursos lo cual hace que el emprendedor
no tenga suficiente dinero para cubrir
sus necesidades básicas que esto incluye
alimentación comida transporte y
vivienda lo cual obliga al emprendedor a
abandonar su sueño para buscar trabajo
por eso es importante buscar nuevas
formas de monetización las cuales te
permitan desde el día uno generar los
recursos necesarios para que la empresa
siga viva desde algún ejemplo
en concreto todos hemos oído hablar de
la impresión 3d como la impresión 3d va
a cambiar el mundo de la medicina de la
construcción del transporte cómo vamos a
poder imprimir pulmones órganos tejidos
cómo vamos a poder imprimir cuartos e
inclusive casas cómo vamos a poder
imprimir vehículos todo eso suena
fantástico pero todas estas ideas vienen
en base a una suposición y la suposición
es el peor enemigo del año de la
monetización
ahora tomando esto en cuenta ya les puse
un ejemplo de lo que pasó la semana
pasada en mi juego en mi noche de juegos
de mesa todos estos elementos con los
que yo me divertí con mis amigos fueron
gracias a la impresión 3d la impresión
3d está cambiando el mundo de los juegos
de mesa de una forma nueva que se está
acercando al usuario la forma de
matización de esta nueva rama del 3d es
por medio de suscripciones el usuario
busca a la artista que mejor resuelve
las problemáticas que él tiene en sus
juegos de mesa por una cuota mensual
recibe todos los modelos de este artista
para mejorar la experiencia de juego de
esta persona el contacto entre la
artista y el diseñador es cercano lo
cual permite al diseñador tener una
mayor empatía con los problemas del
usuario de esta forma lo resuelve
eficazmente y puede monetizar más fácil
estás dichas soluciones si hacemos una
comparación entre esta nueva forma de
monetización contra las otras que
anteriormente dije
tal vez la impresión 3d para juegos
empezando va a salvar el mundo pero la
forma de monetizar y la manera en que le
da vuelta a la idea de la impresión 3d
es un ejemplo valioso de cómo podemos
crear ecosistemas altamente monetizables
con la finalidad siempre de resolver los
problemas reales de nuestros usuarios
para poder llegar a estos giros de
tuerca es necesario conocer al usuario y
no innovar en base a suposiciones sino
teniendo como base a las personas y sus
problemas por ejemplo la impresión 3d
para juegos de mesa resuelve las
problemáticas de falta de variedad de
elementos de los juegos de mesa el alto
costo de los juegos de mesa y la falta
de personalización de los mismos
recuerden siempre tienen que pensar en
sus usuarios y cómo su startup puede
resolver de una manera disruptiva sus
problemáticas claro monetizando en el
proceso así que yo les dejo las
siguientes preguntas como la realidad
virtual puede cambiar de una manera
disruptiva la forma en la que tu empresa
está monetizando como la realidad
aumentada puede resolver los problemas
reales que tienen los usuarios y como el
big data y el match in learning pueden
ayudar a testar
estas preguntas las tenemos que resolver
siempre con empatía de manos de nuestros
usuarios muchas gracias
[Música]